[Applause]
oh amanda i'm so excited
i love your new book so much the the
beautiful text how i mean this one's in
the shape of a fish
this one's in the shape of a vase it's
so unique it's so incredibly you i've
been pouring through it i see all your
notes this is amazing
whoa i was curious with all that you've
accomplished in the space of these last
two years
what is your next dream that you want to
come true
um
one thing i would love to do in the
future would be to recite poetry at an
olympic game i feel like that would be a
really significant moment for literature
so fingers crossed for the 2028 la
olympics that we can get poetry in there
some way i mean if we can wait that long
and like the winter olympics are coming
next year
and
i feel like you have reignited the world
in poetry which is
a profound thing that humans have
created and shared since the beginning
of time i feel it's such an ancient art
but you're modernizing it you're
revitalizing one of the most important
things human beings have within them to
bestow
no pressure
thank you thank you so much for that and
i think you speak to it so
beautifully i think in general we are
experiencing a poetry renaissance i did
not cause it i don't think i'm the
leading force behind it i think i'm just
one piece and kind of this grand opus
that we're seeing from poetry that
there's so many voices speaking up right
now through literature through spoken
word and i'm just so grateful to be
one of them and so it's really just a
homegoing for me because i've always
thought reading books poetry was
cool and exciting and modern and i think
it's you know looking at this year that
we're starting to see people come to
that understanding as well you've had a
crash course in confidence building
you came onto the scene you changed it
as we know it you've talked about
running for president which i cannot
wait for how soon i mean what year are
we eligible and by we i mean thank you
all of us on your journey what year is
this happening
2036. okay
i know that poetry has always inspired
you i know that um hannah montana has
also
been a source of inspiration is this
true explain
i love this hannah montana disgust
uh well
when i was growing up and i think this
was for so many other girls my age you
know hitting my
channelsthebomb.com you were like oh
look at this
you know girl living the double life and
it was so funny because you know i'd be
in like elementary school or whatever
singing that song the best of both
worlds and it's something that actually
makes me really laugh now because i feel
like that meaning i'm this poet i'm kind
of nerdy and geeky and for a lot of my
life i was kind of anonymous or felt
invisible for many reasons and then i
look up and in six minutes all of a
sudden so many people know my name and
on my face and so i feel like just
inside my own body and existence there's
two different realities which are always
fighting and negotiating each other
which is
what is it like to
exist where so many people know your
name and also what brings you joy is
just to watch the world while you're
unnamed and so i'm just trying to
you know journey through that and stay
humble and live in it but yeah hannah
montana was the was the og
was the og for sure i love this so
much
because when someone is as smart
well-spoken running for president and
living on that mountaintop it's like oh
cool hannah montana too perfect in fact
you do love pop culture and i was
wondering if you would give us your
words on some pop culture trends
okay
all right we're calling it the final
five pop culture poetry edition
all right five things in pop culture
that are inspiring you right now
it's hard to narrow it down to five
things but five things i'm loving right
now are um
one the tv show dickinson on apple tv
um huge fan of hamilton the musical i
will be playing that until i'm like 98
years old
um i am a huge fan of star trek so loved
that left the star check new films as
well and uh star trek discovery next
generation i'm a huge nerd so that's me
um though that's literally my
my treasure chest and i love um hans
zimmer
who makes the musical compositions for
so many of the films that we see in
theaters nowadays so yes oh and also i'm
like listing off so many things that
come to mind and an author that i love
is also um ocean vong who wrote on earth
they're beautifully gorgeous so i've
that's that's literally if you were had
to do like a vision board of the five
things that i love
that's it thank you so much i love
talking meaning depth poetry pop culture
all of it with you
your new book which is just as good as
it gets call us what we carry
poems is available now and guess what
i'm so excited to share this
everyone in the audience is going to go
home with a
[Applause]
you
copy
[Music]